so when Donald Trump was first elected
we had this conversation on the show
which did quite well on YouTube by the
way I should mention about whether in
the Trump era the President of the
United States is still the so-called
leader of the free world and leader of
the free world it's not it's not really
a literal term but it's the idea of sort
of the most important player in from
Western democracies geopolitically and
typically it's sort of considered that
it's the president of the United States
and at the time we said it already seems
like we're seeing a shift and it seems
like the shift is going in the direction
of maybe German Chancellor Angela Merkel
being the so-called leader of the free
world again it's a sort of amorphous
discussion because it's not an official
title but increasingly we've seen the
relationships of the United States with
our European allies strained we've seen
trade disagreements with our European
allies we've seen the Paris climate deal
Fiasco with Donald Trump we've seen
Trump off-again on-again indited NATO
and we don't know what his latest
position is on NATO but at least at some
points he has said that NATO is a very
very bad thing and then there's sort of
general question that now has come up in
advance of the North Korea summit and
after Donald Trump just saying hey we're
pulling out of the Iran deal of whether
the United States can even really be
trusted
to maintain their part of the bargain
their end of the bargain when it comes
to deals in general and we now actually
have a statement from German Chancellor
Angela Merkel who says that Europe can
no longer count on the United States for
military protection the protection of
the US military umbrella and that Europe
will quote have to take its destiny into
its own hands and this is related
seemingly not only to Donald Trump's
actual actions of late but also to the
to the policy of America first in
whatever way you would interpret that
now I want to say something here that is
sort of maybe surprising to some which
is that I don't know that this is bad in
every sense and I'm gonna try to explain
what I mean right one interpretation of
what Merkel is saying is you know Europe
can't count on the United States
military it's an indictment of Trump's
foreign policy it's an indictment of
diplomacy under Trump and
and there's this idea which is I think
an accurate one that the u.s. is an
increasingly erratic player even though
our European alliances go back a long
time and we're considered to be serious
and lasting European allies can't really
trust anymore that the United States is
going to be there in shared defense of
Europe whatever may come up that's true
that's a concern and it's something I've
been talking about a lot which is if the
US can't be counted on to stick the
deals and stick with allies our
diplomatic power is very much hurt
because other countries can't trust us
and in fact that plays directly into the
Russian strategy which is hey let's
cause as much chaos as possible in the
diplomatic West interfering in
partnerships between the United States
and allies is something that is a huge
win for the Russian geopolitical
strategic goals breaking the Iran deal
is part of it putting cracks in our
relationships with our allies as part of
it and this is why Russia would prefer
Trump over Hillary but I want to mention
another side to this which is that in a
sense isn't it good in a way for the
expectation of the US as the world's
policeman to go away right this is not
me being an isolationist but we
shouldn't want the world to expect that
the United States will come to the
rescue
at any time and I want to be clear if we
have an alliance if we've made a deal if
we're part of NATO if we're part of the
Iran deal we should stick to the deal we
should hold up our end of the bargain
I'm not cheering bailing on deals but
from the point of view of resisting the
military-industrial complex and
resisting the idea that the US will
spread democracy through military action
and everything that sort of came from
the Bush Wolfowitz Bolton stuff
we shouldn't want there to be an
expectation that the United States will
come to the rescue of whoever needs
rescuing and that is an indirect maybe
effect of what Donald Trump is doing
it's not actually relevant to the
European alliances right the European
alliance says I am hugely concerned
about but it's something to keep in mind
but Merkel is right and it's all laid
out in Alexander Duggan's 1997 book
foundations of geopolitics this is yet
another one of Russia's stayed
goals when it comes to sewing
geopolitical chaos coming to fruition
the rift that is this sort of growing
rift or crack I don't know what other
way to say it between our Western
European allies and the United States
plays directly into Russian goals and to
the extent that Donald Trump is
responsible for that it's something that
we should all be really concerned with
and of course you'll have people on the
right who say hey good it is America
first and that's it Trump's doing the
right thing and being tough period
there's a lot there I just wonder if
this is an indictment on our politics
that the two parties are so far apart
from each other because you if you have
the Democrats who will get us into the
Paris climate Accord and get us into the
Iran deal and then we elect a Republican
president like Trump or like pretty much
any Republican actually because they
were all against the Iran deal they're
all against the Paris climate Accord
yeah and we're just going back and forth
between those two parties there's no
wonder why the Europe and the rest of
the world can't count on us you can't
blame them you can't blame them and this
is what I said a few days ago which is
if you're North Korea about to negotiate
with Trump and you see that Trump bailed
on the Iran deal what makes you think
that whatever you negotiate with Trump
now for a North Korea deal is actually
going to be something that sustains it's
very very dangerous territory to be
going into and Trump is not getting us
into that haphazardly or aimlessly he's
deliberately doing it as if it's some
kind of good policy it's very very scary
stuff today's episode of the program is
made possible in part by coin schedule
which is a listing site for
cryptocurrency icos that's been around
since 2016 and it was actually one of
the first websites to show helpful
listing information about icos where you
can look them up by name by industry by
start and end date and you'll get from
coin schedule a score for each IC o----
that can help you better assess how
careful you should be if you are looking
at investing in any particular IC o----
coin schedule like me says that they
hate scams and one of the guys from coin
schedule was actually telling me about
how they do everything they can to weed
out the scam IC o---- so that they
straight-up don't appear
their website and it seems that they've
learned a lot from doing this over the
past two years coin schedule is also a
really good resource for finding
information about upcoming
cryptocurrency related conferences they
also post crypto news and if you're
watching this on YouTube I put a link to
the coin schedule website at the top of
the description to be clear nothing on
coin schedule should be considered
personalized investment advice icos are
risky everybody should do their own
research and make the decisions that are
right for them